siempre me siempre me gustó recorrer los
campos de san josé una vez recorriendo
los campos de rodríguez me encontré con
esta imagen ellas rosas y su ropa
aliento
esta imagen me cautivó me transmitió una
mezcla de sensaciones
sus texturas sus colores
el misterio me acerque poco a poco y le
tome una fotografía rosa me abrió las
puertas de su casa
y fotografía sus detalles y texturas tu
cocinas o gallinas tu familia
siempre trabajé en temas relacionados al
campo
pero este momento fue un disparador para
trabajar y abordar a través la
fotografía la mujer rural'
conocí muchas mujeres
me acuerdo de una vez
de mariela de boliche de campaña la
polola que me decía
a mí me encanta vivir en el campo me
siento libre
pero somos pocos cada vez somos menos
algo hay que hacer
y en ese momento empecé a contar esa
historia
yo nací en san jose y mi familia se mudó
cuando era muy chiquita montevideo y
tuve la oportunidad de aprovechar toda
esa inmensidad de oferta cultural y
educativa que tiene la capital
y empecé a estudiar bellas artes
administración y realice cursos y
talleres relacionados a fotografía
puede conocer docentes increíbles que
hicieron que me enseñaron a creer en mis
proyectos y en mis historias
luego a los 25 años me enamoré
de un maragato que está por acá y
formamos una familia con tres hijos tres
tesoros que también están por acá
y volví a san josé
y que me pasaba
en ese momento que no fuese tanto pero
no había una propuesta educativa
relacionada a la fotografía entonces
empecé a viajar a montevideo
a realizar cursos se nos iba venía y
venía hasta que un día dije bueno esto
no está bien
y ahí me di cuenta que a veces la mejor
manera de encontrar lo que buscamos es
crearlo
y empezó a crear invitaba a amigos
fotógrafos a realizar talleres en san
jose y compartirlos con los interesados
y así poquito a poco
por un tema
una mezcla de la pasión por la
fotografía
de este interés por la gestión cultural
es que
nace la idea y surge el festival
internacional de fotografía sanjosé foto
la frase anterior que mencioné es de
carolina curbelo y me identifica mucho
más representa
el festival empezó como una iniciativa
privada pequeño
empezamos a golpear puertas a pedir
ayuda en lo que hicimos a mucha gente y
pudimos crearlo en el 2014 fue su
primera edición
luego ya pasó a la órbita municipal del
gobierno departamental 2016 2018 seguir
y siguió creciendo estuvo cada vez más
lindo
yo les quiero mostrar algo de lo que es
san jose photo
[Música]
aquí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
bueno sanjosé fotos fueron tres días
intensos fue una fiesta una fiesta de la
fotografía tres días intensos de
talleres de exposiciones de charlas de
debates
tres días de locura que venían
referentes de la fotografía
latinoamericana a nuestro a nuestro
pueblo a compartir sus experiencias y
sus conocimientos con la gente de acá
vamos
la verdad que es una experiencia difícil
de transmitir quiero leerles algunos
datos
[Música]
algunos datos estadísticos de lo que
pasó en el festival
y no necesitamos más de 3000 personas
vinieron fotógrafos de chile argentina
bolivia brasil españa estados unidos
suiza y francia
el festival estaba posicionado como el
3er
festival de américa latina' me llamo
fotógrafo de national geographic de
magnum
y mucho más
estos datos estadísticos están
buenísimos
pero a mí lo que más me importaba era el
impacto que tenía el festival en la
gente
y bueno tenía tres objetivos bien claros
desde su comienzo
quería que fuera un festival horizontal
porque a veces me pasaba
y bueno cuatro festivales y estaban los
participantes por un lado y estaban los
invitados por otros no había encuentros
entonces no quería que pasara esto ahora
también quería que fuera un festival
auténtico de sanjosé se mostrará tal
cual es
al cual somos
y por último lo más importante que
quería era que fuera un festival de
participación de la comunidad con una
fuerte participación
la sala expositiva del festival pasó a
ser la ciudad misma no había cómo estar
no no había cómo estar ajeno a esa
actividad como ser indiferente los
vecinos se sorprendían en la mañana con
estas gigantografías en toda la plaza
y empezaron a pasar cosas cosas
grandiosas
los niños llenaban la plaza jugaban se
emocionaban o compartían con las
maestras y juego y luego compartían en
la clase lo que iban viviendo en el
festival el último fue con el tema
vínculos
niños que nacieron en la era digital y
no conocían lo que era la fotografía
analógica
y el festival les mostró la magia de lo
que ocurre en la fotografía como esto
en el laboratorio se trata de esta
también de una experiencia junto a ser
que sea hermosa la imagen
y bojan
y siguieron pasando cosas nosotros como
queríamos esa participación hicimos
talleres previos al festival siete meses
antes y nos encontrábamos con con estos
adultos mayores emocionándose con las
fotos antiguas de archivo de san jose
te reconocían en ellas
hablaba de la historia de la memoria de
san jose lo que era lo que es
o cosas como esta se me ocurrió la idea
de colgar una foto de marcos lópez en la
catedral
una foto que habla de la última cena
quería generar debate y reflexión porque
un poco el arte también busca eso no
igual nunca me imaginé que iba a generar
tanto debates pero estuvo buenísimo
y acá un poco las repercusiones de lo
que fue
esta foto en fin me da mucha ternura me
pongo como a cuestionarme que estarán
pensando estos niños tan chiquitos
viendo estas fotografías
y pasaban cosas como estas nosotros
intervenimos la ciudad con las fotos
enormes porque todas las por todos
lugares por todos los lugares
y sorprendimos pero la vez pasada estos
son ya se instala con su
máquina de tejedora de telar inspirada
en una foto que hay una abeja y empieza
a tejer es impresionante ese juego que
el arte produce no se juega
también queríamos el festival
no fuera solamente en la plaza y bueno
lo llegamos a todas partes y queríamos
que todas las instituciones culturales
estuvieran comprometidas con la
actividad muchas veces pensaba pasa que
estaba una por un lado otra otra
institución por otro acá estábamos todos
en lo mismo
mostrábamos también bueno acá está en el
parque mostrábamos también nuestra
cultura a esta raza con su música la
gastronomía
[Música]
a vista de lo que se ve desde aquí
y esto es un señor mayor que se llama
daniel gimeno y me pidió si podía
alcanzar el domingo 6 me encantó
616 de fundamento
está mal
este para mí es un momento muy simbólico
porque el festivo el último festival
hablaba de vínculos y acá se encuentra
catering es la principal editora de
national geographic que nos transmitía
que el momento más importante que había
habido en el festival era este era la
música que daniel le había regalado
mostrándose como es danielle
eso que a veces pasa de qué
pensamos que estamos tan lejos de
algunas personas pero en realidad
estamos tan cerca y sé que daniel está
por acá en el estado
[Aplausos]
gracias a él
negocian un poco
bueno pasaban cosas así también un
encuentro de mujeres los úlimos
redactamos una proclama la leímos
hablaba de la desigualdad de género de
la desigualdad de falta de equidad de la
mujer en el ámbito fotográfico
y después teníamos la noche zancos de
fotos seguían la noche y eran los
momentos quizás más relajados de más
disfrutes donde se seguirán potenciando
proyectos entre fotógrafos argentinos
chilenos en pinos uruguayos
miramos todos todos unos acá en este
delito en testimonio que me gusta mucho
y había una persona de todo américa
argentino brasilero
aprecian y esperamos todo igual
y nada pasó preciosos
todo esto no se hace sola obviamente
para crear es bueno rodearse de personas
comprometidas profesionales luchadoras
con valores para trabajar en armonía
aparte hay algo que acá yo no les estoy
contando y no se ve pero también hay en
el festival desilusiones fracasos
agotamiento planes que no se concretan
el plan a no sale el hambre tampoco el
cdl de
entonces es importante estar contenida y
que no tengamos entre todos para
nosotros para el equipo que es mucho más
grande de lo que se ve ahí
es un desafío también las próximas
ediciones
porque bueno
se trata de apuntar a la excelencia
y el festival va creciendo y los
servicios bueno tenemos mucha fuerza y
muchas ganas que continúe el festival
más de todos
este festival también surge porque hay
una necesidad interna mía de centralizar
todo esto que estaba que pasaba en la
capital
y en san josé no yo quería que las cosas
pasaran acá en san josé porque el
festival acá
y bueno sin duda que el equipo de
voluntarios que teníamos que lo dejaron
todo
una pieza imprescindible trabajaban
desde las 8 de la mañana a las 10 de la
noche sin parar
por simple interés y sin nada
por el simple gusto y disfrute y de
apoyo a esta actividad
hoy por hoy el festival se sigue
potenciando y el entusiasmo se contagió
y entre fechas entre festivales y
festivales siguen pasando cosas como
estas nos reunimos con los voluntarios
y generamos actividades vimos varios
proyectos potenciamos la cuenta de
instagram
everyday sanjosé wing creamos una
muestra un concurso primero una muestra
destaca en el café del teatro
y que va la intención es que llevarla a
otras localidades de san josé
tenemos varios proyectos
por ejemplo crear un laboratorio
fotográfico analógico
tenemos proyectos colectivos crear
bibliotecas móviles
y eso es buenísimo que genera el
festival que esté vivo
hoy por hoy considero la fotografía como
una herramienta de cambio social
tiene un potencial potencial enorme
y bueno acá vuelvo a mis inicios rosa y
yo les invito a crear porque en zancos y
se pueden hacer cosas grandes chicas lo
que ustedes quieran hacer les invito a
crear ya contar sus historias porque sus
historias son nuestras historias y
nuestras historias puedan estar las
historias de san jose y su gente muchas
gracias